fire why do I still feel guilty kill can
be a good thing it's a solas call to
action the indication that your work is
not yet finished may
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we finally
got an official version of the daredevil
season two trailer got our first look at
electra and the Punisher so most of this
breakdown is going to be about them just
because daredevil is the intersection of
a lot of different types of TV a lot of
different comic book genres I'm going to
think of Jon Bernthal playing The
Punisher as being like Omar from the
wire because so many TV writers that
work on shows like this are in love with
a wire what they're selling it as is
daredevil versus Punisher as in you know
Punisher obviously a good character but
just a really crazy good character that
daredevil is gonna have to stop from
going over the line daredevil will
totally push people over the sides of
buildings but it won't kill them
Punisher doesn't have that problem he is
totally happy to shoot every person in
the face if you're looking for a comic
book to read about daredevil versus
Punisher it's real easy because there is
a comic book called daredevil versus
Punisher I just recommend you read that
it's a six-issue series so it's not that
long in every single title is a play on
the idea of crossing the line like issue
one is called good deeds bad deeds then
there's the big squeeze victory now !
over the line the unraveling then the
second chance is the name of the last
title so the Netflix series season two
is going to be all about the punisher
unleashing his brand of justice
daredevil trying to help people and help
the punisher at the same time help the
punisher to stop killing people why then
you ask is Punisher probably not going
to end up being a member of the
defenders team up we'll just a side step
into civil war territory captain america
civil war this is really funny memory I
have of marvel civil war of the comic
book Civil War where Punisher saves
spider-man spider-man almost gets killed
Punisher saison takes them back to
Captain America's underground team
Punisher offers his help to team cap but
the rest of the heroes just look at him
and shake their edges you're just way
too crazy we're going to go ahead and
pass you just keep doing your own thing
so Punisher regardless of the outcome of
daredevil season to it's just gonna
continue to do his own thing although he
will continue to show up during the
Netflix series a lot of you are also
asking his Punisher going to end up in
the movies he's a freaking huge
character Jon Bernthal looks like he's
gonna have an amazing performance why
wouldn't you put them in the movies the
only answer I have for that is is I
think that what they would do is just
have him cameo in the Avengers films or
like like the big team up films there
have been
rumors that he's been seen on the set of
Captain America Civil War but I can't
confirm that and there's already so many
characters in that either way think of
Punisher in this netflix universe and in
the movie universe is being kind of a
free agent I think given the tone of the
character he probably wouldn't work
really well on agents of shield because
that's on ABC it's a little bit lighter
tone daredevil can be as dark and gritty
as it wants I feel like if they try to
take him on agents of shield they would
have to hamstring the character a little
bit so that's one place I'm hoping to
not see him show up what about electro
though well she's also kind of a good
character who has been bad in the past
she is a creation of Frank Miller the
first time she showed up in the comics
she was a bad character like she was
part of the hand but then she's also
been part of the chase she's been part
of Thunderbolts she's gone all over the
place but she's not quite as crazy as
Punisher so I am expecting her to team
up with daredevil eventually but when
they first meet she's probably going to
be Daredevils enemy that that would be
very true to the comics so I'm actually
kind of hoping to see them fight quite a
bit it does look like based on this face
covering that she'll be part of the hand
and the instinct will be back for season
two so they will continue that storyline
of the chaste versus the hand that's
like a mystical battle I think they'll
kind of save a little bit of that for
Iron Fist to just because his character
is rooted in more supernatural things
than daredevil is this character that
everybody saw in daredevil season one
this is Stone he's just one of the
members of the chaste so I'm not really
expecting to see a ton of supernatural
thing show up in daredevil season two I
think it'll be relatively street-level
practical these are street-level heroes
they're going to face street-level
problems but I think that they will
allude to supernatural things
particularly through this chase vs hand
storyline the really cool thing that
Mike Coulter you know who's playing luke
cage and Jessica Jones right now said is
that they're currently filming Luke Cage
although we probably won't see a whole
lot from that till after daredevil
season two like they're promoting
jessica jones daredevil season two right
now first things first then they'll
start promoting Luke Cage both daredevil
and Jessica Jones are Hell's Kitchen
based shows like that area of New York
the weird thing is is like in this
trailer we don't see the Avengers Tower
the cameras just pointed at the wrong
part of New York just imagine the
avengers tower being just a little bit
off screen it's in Midtown hell's
kitchen is a little bit further south of
that Luke Cage on the other hand might
take place up in Harley
or even up in the Bronx like a slightly
different part of New York as they
continue to do netflix series I expect
their sphere of influence to grow like
daredevil season one was highly
localized to Hell's Kitchen I think
they'll start radiating out from New
York a little bit as these series get on
and on they haven't confirmed it yet we
haven't seen Jessica Jones yet but I do
think that each of these netflix series
will continue on as long as Netflix
wants them to continue on they're all
very successful so we can see like five
seasons of each of these shows they're
much easier to shoot because they only
do 13 episodes this season they don't do
like 23 so it's a lot easier to get the
actors just answer the question I know
you guys are all asking to know they
haven't said anything about iron fist
only that Coulson really wants to be in
it in real life Clark Gregg's favorite
Marvel character is Danny rant so
naturally he would want to be in that
serious so if Coulson does show up it'll
probably be during iron fist but before
the big defenders team up but it is time
to get hype in case you guys didn't know
Jessica Jones all drop all the episodes
will drop on November 20th I'm gonna do
as many videos as I can for that I
probably won't be able to do like 13
just because it'll all drop it once but
i'll try to do at least like five or six
videos so be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're probably due for a
captain america civil war trailer in the
next month too i've already done a
couple punisher daredevil videos so I'll
put some bonus links in the description
if you want to learn a little bit more
about their history in the comics I feel
like I need to go by like my dear devil
t-shirts now I need like three or four
new daredevil shirts while you guys wait
for my next video I have a Walking Dead
QA and there are a couple other trailers
from New York Comic Con I may or may not
get to those I'll try to but you guys
can click here to catch up from walking
dead episode one last night is freaking
crazy let's all remember Shane is the
Punisher and you can click here for the
viral teaser from Batman V Superman just
teasing some Brainiac things I think
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you